كيف يبدو المشهد في مدينه باخ موت شرقيه
اوكرانيا
مقاتلات اوكرانيه تسهم في سد الهجمات التي
لا تتوقف على المدينه
[موسيقى]
اهم ما نحصل عليه من المساعدات هي
المصابيح والكشافات لا كهرباء في المدينه
ولمياه ممتمون لكل من يسهم في تخفيف
المعاناه هذه اول مره ناتي فيها الى هذه
النقطه لكنهم يوزعون المساعدات يوميا
يدرك الجيش الاوكراني ان الاوضاع مقبله
على منعطف سيكون له ما بعدها
وشراسه المعارك في باقي المناطق توحي بان
الامر لن يكون سهلا
لذا شرعت الوحدات الهندسيه العسكريه في شق
الخنادق ورفع التحصينات وسط المدينه
هؤلاء الجنود مسرون على ان لا تكون مهمه
مهاجمين سهله
ويحرسون على زرع العقبات في وجههم بكل
الطرق الممكنه
قد نخوضها في المدينه اتمنى ان لا نصل الى
هذه المرحله لكن نتمنى لا يكفي يجب ان
نستعد جيدا ارى ان الجميع يبالغ فيه امك
هم مجرد اللصوص المجرمين يحملون بنادق
ليست في المدينه محاصره يقول الاوكرانيون
لكنها ليست في افضل حال وتحتاج الى تحضير
تستعيد القوات الاوكرانيه لاسوا
الاحتمالات في مدينه باخمد وتبقي جاهزيه
المقاتلين مرتفعه في الميدان بينما يتكفل
اخر هنا بابقاء اعينهم مفتوحه على كل
تحركات المهاجمين مركز قياده الاستطلاع في
الجبهه الشرقيه
شاشات ترصد كل التحركات عبر مئات مسيرات
باختلاف احجامها
العين الساهره على الخطوط الاماميه كما
يسمونها اكتسب العاملون هنا خبره كبيره مع
الوقت ان لوحدتهم دورا كبيرا لا يقل عن
دور المقاتلين في الخطوط الاماميه
والمدفعيه عن جبهه محمود العدو قائم على
المشاه الذين يخسروا الكثير منهم كل يوم
هؤلاء المقاتلون
كما يملك كل جانب المدفعيه والدبابات
لكنما يميزهم هو السرعه اتخاذه من القرار
وقد هم من عزيمه يستبدونها من كونهم
يدافعون عن ارضهم عمر الحاجه الجزيره
مدينه ضخمه